they go welcome to screen chunky central
this episode is brought to you by mafia
3 family is who you die for oh my gosh
oh how good is it to be in the
air-conditioning right now oh this
heat am i right hey man let's bring out
our guest yes we have epic guests they
are the creators and one of the stars of
the brand-new HBO show Vice Principals
Jodi pleasure this is so cool oh wow hey
guys how's your con goin so good is our
first stop of the day oh we got you
fresh fresh nice life yet not yet not
too hungover okay all right get these
gentlemen some drinks is this your first
Comic Con er if you've done comic-con
a couple few times oh I created
comic-con you Wow
yeah I've been here a few times this
place is it's amazing it's great first
one for me yep nice
so Vice Principals give us the gist of
the show for those who don't know vice
principal
Vice Principals is about zookeepers yeah
two zookeepers who it is about two vice
principals weirdly enough who end up
getting locked in this power struggle
for the spot of the principal job but it
goes very dark and strange from there
but that's how we get people in the door
I have a question I'm a huge eastbound
and down fan as well right guys yeah are
we is there like a shared universe here
at all but you put my chance
yeah like Tarantino there's a lot of the
same spirit in there but we it's a
separate story altogether but the world
is the same Thor lives in this world oh
part of the MCU and
is what what's the name of the character
you play in Vice Principals I play Neil
Gambian Walton Goggins plays Lee Russell
Oh walk walk dog that guy's IMDB is off
the charts he was in I remember one year
he was in Lincoln he was in plays yeah
come a long way when he started his
career he was always cast as like racist
teen number three and now he's worked
his way up to work with turns the
weirdest role you've had all of them
have been surprising would you quantify
though the we're I think the strangest
one for me has been the one I just
finished which was alien covenant it's
like every day on that it was just like
are you serious
you know you know what people will ask
me like oh are you the comic relief
there is no comedy in the movie at all
it is dark and brutal the whole movie is
and so yeah there's no jokes it's a guys
getting murdered and stuff exploding
from all right I know these guys don't
like spoilers but I love spoilers tell
us does an alien burst out of your chest
I can't say game over man I can't say do
you kill the Queen alien is it gonna be
better than prometheus
you know I'm I'm in the news but I think
this is this is on par with alien I mean
it's just Danny better actor you were
Michael Fassbender you know everyone
would always ask that question on set
he's actually he is such a strangely
funny guy you would never imagine it
when I was on set the first day I was
there I was kind of like I was just
nervous trying to feel my way around
yeah and he was like talking to himself
like what is he saying over there
he was like reciting lines from flat she
was just kind of just walking around
just like saying line she's like a big
fan of comedy and he had some pretty
incredible like acting tips for me he
was saying that if you ever have to like
think about something all you should do
on screen is just like do long division
in your
and that gives the impression you have
to play a serial killer you focus on
like your ears touching the back of your
head and he could do it this way one
more thing about Michael Fassbender he's
got a real hog on him real big did he
show you how big yeah we can confirm
that because Danny sucked it all the
time he brings all the time how does it
go with it yeah he's brainer with him
tonight you guys are a really awesome
creative pairing by the way you've been
together well the first major thing was
foot fist way how long have you guys
known each other work together we went
to film school together and we were
neighbors our freshman year in the dorm
so we've known each other since we were
18 so over 20 years yep we just proved
that's one thing I know everyone asked
about film school to me like the best
thing I've also it's finding someone
like this right 100% you know all the
stuff that we've done we went to school
with David Green and Jodi and everyone
from our production designer to our
camera operators sound mixer I mean
everything riders they're all guys we've
known since we were teenagers and so
that was well I wouldn't ask question
cuz I love the first I got to see the
first episode it's on hopefully you all
did it started in HBO it's on every
Sunday what you Bill Murray yes you must
have a Bill Murray story everyone has a
Bill Murray story I mean I imagine you
look up to him like we all do yes yeah I
mean he's he's an icon everyone loves
Bill Murray and one thing about Bill
Murray got a real hog on him not as big
as fast it's pretty big I suck cool
we heard he you know we went to scout
the show in Charleston South Carolina
and we were kind of deciding whether
we're gonna shoot there or not and we're
flying back to Los Angeles and and I
heard someone say my name I turned
around and he was sitting right next to
us in the plane and some of the whole
flight he just convinced us why we had
to shoot Vice Principals in South
Carolina and then once we got there like
he convinced us to come here we the
least to get it was being the goddamn
thing South Carolina why did why did he
insist you know he's from there he's
lived there for years and Charleston is
a just a super cool town I didn't spend
a lot of time there until we shot there
but it's awesome do you have like dilute
the number because I everyone talks
about it's impossible to track them down
this number come on man I got the email
that must be cool but honestly because
you you know you're a comedy guy now
it's who else do you look up to it I
mean it's I imagine he's up there right
oh yeah he's got to be the top but yeah
I mean growing up I guess the Golden
Girls every cast member so any any
stories from real life regarding your
Vice Principals I imagine you were a
real a real real class clown a real
in high school
Jodie was really nice so that's very
cool we have actually we want to run a
couple of scenarios by you so if you
were a principal what would you do if
some of this stuff went down at your
school okay okay like how would you drop
the hammer or would you believe
principal or vice-principal
well he's gunning for princes right you
know what let's just say you're either a
principal or vice-principal
okay okay somebody keeps pooping in the
swimming pool come on Joe you know how
to deal with this right you would you
would you would diving equipment and
just wait underneath for them and they
don't mitt and then play it on all the
monitors at school to humiliate them
yeah I got alright and I got one based
on my one of my favorite movies if
Europe Eastern European terrorists have
taken over the school hostage you
suspect they might just want their bonds
being held in the vault under the campus
what do you do lock down the school
handle business yeah you get into the
air conditioning ducts
yeah you make explosives and try to get
to the roof yeah wait soldiers anybody
see that movie that's a good one Sean
Astin yeah underrated
it's like diehard but at a school school
yes got junior so good
I prefer taps though if you're gonna go
to school where people murder oh yeah
quite a standoff and that okay here's
another one everybody's playing this
Pokemon go instead of paying attention
in class what do you do Danny
Jodi beat up someone said beat him
that's what you do you beat up yeah grow
up okay get a job you haven't tried
Pokemon go yet oh I played up I bagged
me about 50 of those little
my girlfriend hasn't
spoken to me in three days there's a
Pokemon go okay at your school is the
following allowed corporal punishment
yeah of course right it's I mean if it's
not allowed you should be trying all the
time to get that MP and loving
consensual relationships between
students and teachers all right well we
also got some real guidance from we want
to see if you could help us be guidance
counselor's too okay so we got some real
questions from teens post on reddit oh
yeah this is the real there's
really no questions we want to see how
you guys generation over summer vacation
I just sit at home and play games I
don't really feel like doing anything
else to be honest but I feel like a
piece of like I need to be doing
something productive what do you think
start smoking pot and then they won't
feel so bad about it
you'd be too lazy to worry let me ask
you a couple questions about teens
should they vape
I like just old school I feel like
there's gonna be some weird thing from
vaping that happens and there's like
some new weird health scare you don't
know about that I think just right go
with the health scares we already know
about just so you're saying
kids don't vape smoke here's another one
music has never been my thing what do
you say are the most popular songs that
I should be familiar with you got this
Jodi yeah help a kid out get out it's a
real kid save a life should I cut my
afro for my formal dance no pubic hair
yes yes I've always been a big fan of
the half row don't like the half size
other cool dudes absolute oh yeah like
kind of like some kitten play going
on I would say trim but don't fully
commit to the gray and then in regards
Jodi what are your preferences in
regards to pubic hair I like to trim but
leave a little just so you know try to
get it natural yeah good call I like the
Cryptkeeper look just get them all
Gong's they're like two or three long
ones on your balls only just long hair
under balls while I have because I know
we got to wrap you up soon but I'm
curious another what project you've done
and I was a big fan was this is the end
oh yeah so funny I'm just curious what's
how close is that to an actual James
Franco house party very close very very
close you know I've never there's
weirder people at James Franco house
party he's weirder than Michael weirder
things happen that Michael Cera getting
his a seat now why sips on his Capri Sun
did you connect with them that accrues
Seth and all them and what it was
through pineapple Express I mean that
was the first was actually through the
foot fish weighed the first film Jody
and I made together Seth and Judd and
those guys saw it and they invited us to
this set of knocked up and we just got
to know those guys from there you guys
are funny so we're gonna connect to you
that's smart that's why they're doing so
well
they didn't seem to know who's funny
yeah they they're always into like who's
you know coming up or anybody's got like
anything going they know so many
comedians that I've never heard of all
kinds of stuff like that they're super
into it nice yeah by that you mentioned
pineapple Express that is like I think
that is one of those underrated comedies
of the past decade or so yeah before
your character so you had a pretty
violent go-around in that movie they're
like did you get hurt at all cuz there
was a there was some serious fight stage
Wow
everyone got heard of that movie James
split his forehead open in the movie
that's why he wears a headband through
half the movies oh wow his forehead was
split open
Seth broke his hand when me and him went
through the coffee table and then when
when Franco hits me in the back of the
head with the bong I got a concussion
and split my head open
and we still went on to shoot for the
rest dude you're like a player just
stays in the game my improv was off that
for the rest of the day I just goes like
a line behind everyone else like one of
the best stoner movies of all time
easily well speaking of so I was curious
cuz you talked to a leak everybody alien
or aliens what's your favorite that's
tough I like them both I think they're
both brought so you know Ridley said
that they didn't even offer him aliens
that's what he told me I think you know
he'll mark James Cameron no more back
wait was there a reason did he say and
now we now he's got it back he would
yeah it's awesome keeps the control
smart man um Danny I want to ask about
your other film legend of the whitetail
deer oh you got that coming up so give
us just the gist cuz I feel really funny
stuff about Jodi's been jamming on this
thing it's just it's about a celebrity
deer hunter who feels like he's losing
touch with his son because of a divorce
so he takes his son and his cameraman
and they go to kill his sons first year
it's like three dudes in the woods
pretty much the whole time and we talked
Josh Brolin into doing it he's uh ya
know great cast and I've heard it
described as just a like a comedy
version of the revenant
it's much harder than the rest
we watch the revenuer like man these
guys aren't doing got a shot to the
sky these guys are fan guys Vice
Principals HBO please check it out Danny
McBride Jody Hill thank you so much yes
thank you so much guys round of applause
and we'll see you next for Power Ranger
stick around thanks so much everybody
thanks again to mafia 3 for sponsoring
this episode
to watch our previous show click the box
to the left and to see everything from
screen junkie central click the box to
the right